Vamos a arrancar directamente con el escenario de hoy.
Imaginemos esto, un paciente varón de 34 años entra caminando a la sala
de urgencias.
El típico caso de la madrugada.
Exacto. Tiene fiebre, digamos unos 38.7 grados centígrados,
frecuencia cardíaca de 104 latidos por minuto
y una presión arterial completamente normal de 128 sobre 74
milímetros de mercurio.
Y me imagino que su estado mental está intacto.
Totalmente lúcido. Un Glasgow de 15 colabora en todo.
Pero, y aquí está el detalle, refiere tener la peor cefalea de su vida.
Es un dolor intenso, continuo, lleva ya 18 horas evolucionando,
no tolera la luz de la sala y, de hecho, ha vomitado unas tres veces.
Claro, un cuadro que enciende alarmas, pero que visualmente puede engañar.
Ahí es donde quiero llegar, porque lo exploras y su cuello se mueve
perfectamente. No hay rigidez en absoluto.
Si el clínico que lo atiende confía ciegamente en los libros de texto clásicos de
semiología, pues le da paracetamol, una palmadita en la espalda y lo manda a casa.
Sí. Y ese paciente, con su cuello maravillosamente flexible,
podría morir en cuestión de horas.
Es un escenario aterrador precisamente porque castiga esa confianza
excesiva que tenemos en lo que podemos ver y tocar.
Y por eso hoy vamos a hacer una inmersión clínica profunda
en este caso. Vamos a usar la evidencia de la plataforma medsemiotics-db para la
meningitis aguda bacteriana. Nuestra misión hoy, digamos, es desglosar la
matemática clínica real detrás de estos signos físicos.
Exacto. Queremos ver exactamente cuánto cambia la probabilidad diagnóstica
con cada hallazgo en la cabecera del paciente.
Y, lo que me parece más fascinante, ¿por qué a veces la evidencia nos
obliga a aceptar que simplemente no podemos calcular esa probabilidad?
Ok, vamos a desglosar esto.
Las apariencias de este examen físico pueden ser una trampa mortal si no entendemos
los números.
Pero antes de meternos de lleno, establezcamos una regla básica sobre cómo vamos a
interpretar la evidencia hoy.
Sí, es crucial. Vamos a mencionar mucho el concepto de cociente de verosimilitud,
o LR, por sus siglas en inglés, likelihood ratio.
Para que sea súper visual, pensemos en el LR como un
multiplicador de apuestas en un casino.
Me gusta esa analogía. O sea, si el LR es mayor a 1, tus sospechas aumentan.
Exactamente. Estás apostando más fuerte a que la enfermedad sí está presente.
Si es menor a 1, tus sospechas disminuyen.
Pero, y esto es clave, si el LR es exactamente
1.0, tu apuesta no se mueve ni un solo milímetro.
El hallazgo es inútil, básicamente.
Totalmente inútil para cambiar tu nivel de certeza.
Es como si no hubieras examinado nada.
Bien, con eso en mente, volvamos a nuestro paciente en la puerta de urgencias.
Fiebre y la peor cefalea de su vida en un adulto joven.
Aquí lanzo la primera pregunta socrática para quien nos escucha, para que la
piensen mientras hablamos.
¿Qué diagnósticos no es permisible pasar por alto en este escenario y con qué
urgencia?
Dejemos un par de segundos para que nuestra audiencia haga su lista mental.
Sí, es un ejercicio de reflejo clínico fundamental.
Mi instinto inicial al ver una cefalea febril es pensar que nueve de cada
10 veces.
Entonces, va a ser un cuadro viral sistémico, una gripe fuerte o algo así.
Claro, y estadísticamente no te equivocas.
Pero la medicina de urgencias no opera solo por probabilidades crudas.
El razonamiento aquí no busca la certeza diagnóstica inmediata, sino que se
basa en lo que llamamos el umbral de acción.
El famoso umbral de acción.
Ajá, y la respuesta que encabeza esa lista de manera indiscutible es la
meningitis aguda bacteriana.
Porque si te equivocas y retrasas el tratamiento, el pronóstico neurológico y la
supervivencia caen en picada en cuestión de horas.
Es, digamos, como jugar a la defensiva en el ajedrez.
No te defiendes del movimiento más probable que va a ser tu oponente.
Te defiendes del movimiento que te hace jaque mate.
Esa es la mentalidad exacta.
En esa misma liga de gravedad entran la encefalitis, la hemorragia
subaracnoidea, un absceso cerebral o incluso una trombosis de senos
venosos.
La prioridad es delimitar ese campo minado antes de dar un
diagnóstico definitivo.
De acuerdo. Ahora, miremos los síntomas que el paciente nos cuenta.
Tiene cefalea, tiene náuseas y tiene vómitos.
Y aquí viene nuestra segunda pregunta socrática.
Estos síntomas orientan a irritación meníngea, pero ¿cuánto aumentan
realmente la probabilidad de meningitis según los datos de medsemiotics-db?
Pensemos en esto un segundo.
Es una pregunta trampa si te soy sincera.
Totalmente. Porque cuando revisé la base de datos, me generó un cortocircuito.
La evidencia marca que la cefalea tiene una sensibilidad de 0.5,
las náuseas tienen una sensibilidad de 0.3 y los vómitos también de
0.3.
Uno pensaría que sumando todo eso, el multiplicador se dispara.
Exacto. Pero en lugar de darnos un cociente de verosimilitud altísimo, la
base de datos etiqueta el estado de estos síntomas individuales como LR no medido,
o sea, cero multiplicador.
¿Por qué la base no hace el cálculo matemático y ya?
Porque medsemiotics-db prefiere la honestidad intelectual antes que inventar números
que parezcan bonitos.
Para calcular el LR, necesitas dos piezas del rompecabezas.
Necesitas la sensibilidad, que es la frecuencia del hallazgo en los enfermos, y
la especificidad, la frecuencia en los sanos.
La fuente original, que es una revisión rigurosa, publica las
sensibilidades agrupadas de estos síntomas,
Pero no publica la especificidad.
Y sin especificidad, matemáticamente no existe el cociente de
verosimilitud.
Pero, a ver, si agrupan datos de un montón de estudios, ¿no pueden, no sé,
estimarlo de alguna forma?
Es que sería como intentar calcular el área de un rectángulo sabiendo solo
el perímetro. La matemática no te deja.
Además, hay un detalle metodológico tremendo aquí.
Las fuentes suelen agrupar las náuseas y los vómitos en una sola estimación de
sensibilidad.
Ah, los fusionan.
No son independientes.
Exacto.
Entonces no puedes aplicar una fórmula para derivar un riesgo cuando los datos de
origen vienen mezclados así y sin la especificidad.
Sería un castillo de naipes estadístico.
Qué locura.
Esto rompe mucho con la intuición médica de ir sumando puntitos en la cabeza.
Tiene náuseas, un punto.
Vomitó, otro punto.
Pero quiero volver a ese 0.5 de sensibilidad de la cefalea.
Porque ahí hay una trampa brutal que debemos discutir.
Sí, la trampa del 50%.
Claro. Si un médico lo lee rápido, una sensibilidad de 0.5
suena a lanzar una moneda, cara o cruz.
El peligro es que llegue un paciente con fiebre que, por alguna razón, no reporta
dolor de cabeza.
Y el médico dice, bueno, sin cefalea no es meningitis, lo cual
es un error garrafal.
Esa sensibilidad de 0.5 significa llanamente que una gran
proporción de los enfermos confirmados no la presenta.
O sea, su ausencia no te autoriza, bajo ningún concepto, a descartar la
enfermedad.
Para nada. El problema es que en la facultad memorizamos los síntomas clásicos casi
como si fueran constantes universales de la física, y no lo son.
Lo cual nos lleva directo al examen físico, que es el momento del caso donde se
caen los clásicos de la medicina.
Nuestro paciente está en la camilla con fiebre, pero con un estado mental
normal y el cuello libre.
Y esto nos lleva a la tercera pregunta socrática de este análisis.
La regla clínica construida sobre la triada de fiebre, rigidez de
nuca y alteración del estado mental tiene reglas estrictas.
¿Qué afirma exactamente esta regla y qué no afirma?
Demos un momento para recordarla.
Es vital tenerla clara porque rige muchas decisiones de guardia.
A ver, en la escuela de medicina nos tatúan esta triada clásica, y la
tentación de firmar el alta cuando faltan dos de los tres componentes es gigante.
¿Cuál es el razonamiento real aquí?
El razonamiento es que esta regla afirma que la ausencia simultánea de
los tres componentes descarta la meningitis.
Simultánea. Las tres cosas ausentes al mismo tiempo.
Ese es el requisito.
La sensibilidad de la presencia de al menos uno de esos tres signos es altísima.
Va de 0.99 a 1.0.
Por eso sirve para descartar.
Pero, ojo, no sirve para confirmar.
Y en nuestro caso, el paciente ya tiene fiebre.
Así que ya tiene uno de los tres.
Exactamente.
La regla ya no lo excluye.
Pero hay algo más fuerte aún.
La propia fuente advierte que si tienes una alta sospecha clínica, un alto
riesgo,
Vas directo a la punción lumbar.
Te saltas la regla por completo.
O sea, ni te molestas en usar la triada para descartar.
Ahora, tengo una duda metodológica sobre la base de datos.
En las fichas, la fiebre sola o la alteración de conciencia sola
aparecen como LR no medido.
Pero la regla combinada sí tiene esos números perfectos de sensibilidad.
¿Por qué pasa eso?
Es un principio clínico y epidemiológico muy elegante.
Exactamente. El rendimiento de una regla combinada no se hereda a sus partes por
separado. El estudio original midió el desempeño del grupo completo, pero
no calcularon el cociente aislado de la fiebre en esa misma cohorte.
Claro, usar el éxito del grupo para validar a un solo individuo sería hacer trampa
con la estadística.
Sería metodológicamente fraudulento, sí.
Y eso nos lleva a la exploración física detallada, ¿no?
Sí, al punto de quiebre absoluto.
Vamos a explorar ese cuello.
El paciente está en decúbito supino.
Hacemos la flexión cervical libre.
El mentón toca el pecho sin ningún dolor.
Pasamos a los signos epónimos.
Signo de Kernig, negativo.
Signo de Brudzinski, negativo.
Aquí va la cuarta pregunta socrática.
El paciente tiene los tres grandes signos meníngeos negativos.
¿Se puede descartar la meningitis y mandarlo a casa con analgesia?
Un segundo para meditarlo.
Aquí es donde incluso los clínicos más razonables suelen equivocarse.
Totalmente. Mi instinto, si veo todo negativo, es pensar que no hay irritación
meníngea.
Pero, ¿qué dicen los números reales?
Las cifras son devastadoras.
Vamos a ver los multiplicadores de apuestas.
La rigidez de nuca tiene un LR positivo de 0.94, con una
sensibilidad de apenas 0.3.
¡Wow!
Y espera, el signo de Kernig tiene un LR positivo de 0.97
y su sensibilidad es de un ínfimo 0.05.
5%.
Y el Brudzinski es un calco.
LR positivo de 0.97 y sensibilidad de 0.05.
A ver, detengámonos en esto, porque es gravísimo.
Un LR de 0.97 o 0.94 es, a efectos
matemáticos prácticos, 1.0.
Es la unidad, sí.
O sea, multiplicas tu sospecha inicial por uno.
La probabilidad no se mueve.
El hallazgo no aporta absolutamente ninguna información.
Si encuentras un Kernig, no confirmas nada.
Y si no lo encuentras, que es lo que ocurre el 95% de las veces, tampoco
descartas nada.
Es un golpe directo al ego del médico explorador.
Llevamos más de un siglo doblando cuellos y piernas en las camas de hospital
basándonos en signos descritos en el siglo XIX.
Pero entonces, ¿por qué se hicieron tan famosos?
¿Por qué funcionaban en su época?
Porque Kernig y Brudzinski describieron esto en pacientes que estaban en
fase terminal, sin antibióticos, con una inflamación meníngea que llevaba
semanas destruyendo todo. Hoy en día vemos a los pacientes en urgencias en las
primeras horas o días. Que el cuello esté libre hoy es exactamente lo
esperable. Descartar una meningitis por un cuello que se mueve bien es
un error histórico grave.
Y entonces surge la gran pregunta.
Si estos signos tienen un cociente de 1 y no discriminan nada, ¿para
qué perder el tiempo explorándolos? Es puro teatro para que el paciente sienta que
lo estamos atendiendo.
No diría teatro, pero su uso actual es muy, muy
específico. Sirven solo para documentar el estado basal del paciente.
Ah, para la evolución.
Exacto. Si lo anotas ahora y en 6 horas vas a revaluarlo y ese
cuello parece una tabla de madera, detectas un deterioro innegable.
Pero lo que no debes hacer nunca es usar esa exploración para decidir si le
haces o no la punción lumbar.
Usarlos como filtro para la punción lumbar es una negligencia basada en una
ilusión estadística. Me queda clarísimo.
Bueno, pero la semiología también ha intentado modernizarse,
¿verdad?
Pasemos a la maniobra de sacudida cefálica.
El famoso jolt accentuation.
Ese mismo.
Quinta pregunta socrática de la inmersión clínica.
Le pides al paciente que gire la cabeza horizontalmente dos o tres veces por
segundo.
Nuestro paciente lo hace y el dolor de cabeza empeora brutalmente.
La evidencia dice que esta maniobra tiene una sensibilidad de 0.653
y una especificidad de 0.704.
Tenemos los dos números.
Pero medsemiotics-db dice que el LR es no medible.
¿Por qué no podemos simplemente dividir los números y sacar el cociente?
Y si la prueba es positiva o negativa, ¿qué hacemos?
Pensemos un poco en esta contradicción.
Parece contradictorio, pero es pura integridad de los datos.
La base de datos no hace aritmética basura.
Aritmética basura. Explícame eso.
Mira, la revisión sistemática que publica esos números les asigna una certeza
de evidencia GRADE muy baja.
Son estimaciones agrupadas de estudios súper heterogéneos.
Si tú tomas una sensibilidad agrupada por un lado, una especificidad por otro,
Ambas con certeza muy baja y las divides para forzar un cociente.
Creas un número que parece muy científico, pero que es fragilísimo.
Exacto. Un espejismo matemático.
Durante mucho tiempo se enseñó que esto tenía un LR de 2.2,
basado en un estudio viejísimo con una muestra pequeñita.
La evidencia moderna destrozó eso.
Así que derivar un número hoy sería engañoso.
Ya veo. ¿Y qué hacemos entonces con nuestro paciente?
La sacudida le dolió muchísimo.
La prueba es positiva.
Con esa especificidad de 0.704, la prueba está
llena de falsos positivos.
A cualquiera con una migraña o una gripe fuerte le va a doler la cabeza si
se la sacudes así.
Así que no te confirma la meningitis.
¿Y si no le hubiera dolido?
¿Si fuera negativa?
La decisión innegociable sigue siendo ir a la punción lumbar.
Ni una prueba positiva ni una negativa cambian el destino de ese paciente.
Nada reemplaza a la aguja.
Lo que nos lleva al tercer movimiento de este análisis, la trinchera real.
¿Qué hacer con todo esto en la consulta?
El momento de la verdad.
Llega el hemograma.
Hay leucocitosis con neutrofilia y la proteína C reactiva está muy elevada.
Y recuerdo el contexto clínico.
Cero focalidad neurológica, no hay debilidad, no hay crisis, no
hay inmunodepresión y el fondo de ojo no tiene papiledema.
Sexta y última pregunta socrática.
¿Cuál es el orden de las actuaciones en la próxima hora y por qué?
Demos unos segundos.
Esta secuencia es literalmente lo que salva el tejido cerebral.
A ver, dándosla.
Es innegociable.
Primero, extracción de hemocultivos y punción lumbar sin ninguna demora.
Y tratamiento antibiótico empírico inmediatamente después de extraer el líquido.
El orden es sagrado. El retraso en el antibiótico es el mayor predictor
de mortalidad aquí.
Claro, pero pongamos los pies en la tierra.
En un hospital real, a veces la punción se retrasa.
Anatomía difícil, el médico está en un paro cardíaco al lado o faltan
insumos. ¿Qué pasa ahí?
Si hay cualquier retraso, el antibiótico va primero, inmediatamente.
Los hemocultivos que ya tomaste van a mantener cierta rentabilidad para aislar el
bicho. Pero ese cerebro inflamado no puede esperar.
El tiempo es cerebro.
Totalmente. Y ojo con este detalle.
Se debe añadir dexametasona intravenosa junto con la primera dosis de
antibiótico. O justo antes.
Eso es para la respuesta inflamatoria.
Exacto. Para mitigar la tormenta inflamatoria que se desata cuando el antibiótico
destruye masivamente a las bacterias en el espacio subaracnoideo.
Buenísimo. Ahora, quiero hacer una pausa gigante para destacar lo que no
se debe hacer.
Porque es un vicio casi universal en los hospitales.
Tienes a este paciente, sin focalidad, alerta, inmunocompetente y
sin papiledema.
El impulso de casi todo el mundo es pedir una tomografía craneal antes de la
punción, para evitar una herniación.
Es un error sistémico gravísimo.
En este paciente específico, pedir la tomografía previa solo añade un
retraso fatal.
Tienes que sumarle el tiempo de transporte, la adquisición de la imagen, que el
radiólogo la lea.
Todo ese tiempo el cerebro se está friendo.
Literalmente.
Y el riesgo real de herniación sin esos signos de alarma clínicos que
mencionaste es ínfimo, ínfimo en comparación con el daño seguro de
retrasar el tratamiento dos horas.
Esto cambia por completo las reglas del juego de cómo vemos al paciente febril
con cefalea intensa.
Hay que redefinir lo que esperamos de la exploración meníngea.
No es una herramienta para evitar la punción.
Exacto.
El hallazgo que realmente decide el caso, el que marca la diferencia entre la vida
y la muerte, no está en cómo se flexiona el cuello.
Está en el recuento celular del líquido cefalorraquídeo.
La demostración de pleocitosis es lo que manda.
Entonces, saber que nuestra clínica de cabecera es tan matemáticamente débil
es paradójicamente una ventaja.
Te obliga a ser más agresivo con la indicación de la punción y más rápido con el
tratamiento empírico.
Esa es la actitud correcta.
La duda te empuja a actuar, no a esperar.
Bien, vamos llegando al cierre de este análisis.
Si la persona que nos escucha hoy, digamos el residente que va a entrar de guardia
esta noche,
¿Sólo pudiera llevarse una cosa para recordar mañana?
¿Cuál sería?
A mí me parece que la mayor lección de este caso es puramente negativa.
Lo es. Es una lección sobre destruir falsas seguridades.
Los signos clásicos, el Kernig, el Brudzinski, la
rigidez de nuca, son falsos amigos clínicos.
Con cocientes cercanos a uno, ni confirman con su presencia ni, lo que es
muchísimo más peligroso, descartan con su ausencia.
O sea, la única regla con poder para descartar es la ausencia simultánea de la
triada completa.
Exactamente. Sin fiebre, sin rigidez, sin alteración mental.
E incluso eso se anula si tu riesgo clínico general es alto.
La moraleja no es que debes aprender a explorar el cuello con más técnica.
La moraleja es que debes puncionar y tratar mucho antes de lo que te enseñaron.
Una conclusión contundente.
Pero antes de irnos, quiero dejar un pensamiento final provocativo flotando en el
aire.
Porque después de revisar toda esta evidencia con lupa, hay un límite
clarísimo que los propios datos exponen.
Sí, el gran elefante en la habitación de la medicina basada en la evidencia.
Exacto.
El artículo de medsemiotics-db revela que ninguna de las fuentes, ninguna,
publica la probabilidad basal de esta enfermedad.
La prevalencia real.
Ajá. Nadie publica cuál es el porcentaje exacto de adultos que llegan a urgencias
por cefalea y fiebre que realmente terminan teniendo meningitis aguda.
Y si no tienes ese número de partida, el teorema de Bayes se queda cojo.
Es un vacío crítico.
La calculadora bayesiana te dice, bueno, este signo multiplica tu sospecha por
dos.
Pero, ¿multiplica por dos a partir de qué número?
Estás aplicando un multiplicador a una probabilidad inicial fantasma.
Tienes que adivinarla tú mismo basándote en tu hospital, en tu experiencia, en el
clima.
Y la pregunta que le dejo a quien nos escuche es esta.
En plena era de la medicina basada en la evidencia,
¿Cómo calibramos nuestra intuición inicial en la puerta de urgencias cuando la
literatura científica ni siquiera nos da el número de partida?
Es un interrogante que da vértigo.
Es algo para reflexionar profundamente la próxima vez que te toque evaluar a un
paciente joven con el peor dolor de cabeza de su vida y un cuello que engañosamente
se mueve a la perfección.
Gracias por acompañarnos en este análisis.
Hasta la próxima.